My Confession is if someone tries to  ghost me I will text them from my  girlfriend's phone pretending to be  someone else and then show up where they  are works like a charm this method is 12  out of 10. what do they do they're just  like oops sorry well they think they're  meeting up with someone else and then  it's just like me  I killed my neighbor's cat and I never  told anyone to my defense I was six I  was playing with this whiskers and I  thought they were way too long so I cut  them  and then I find out it went missing I  asked my dad well you know what happens  if you cut  cats whiskers and he goes like don't  ever do that it's navigation tool it's a  sensory tool it's basically like if you  do that it's like blindfolding a person  and then they get disoriented and scared  and I was like holy no I'm a larper  which is live action role-playing  basically adults and sometimes young  kids fighting each other on a  battlefield in equipment